I just have nothing come on I got this
job this family
but nothing lasts forever
I heard you had to leave in a hurry
it's never easy these days
so what are you going to do I've lived a
lot of lives but I'm done running from
my past
[Music]
I know you're out there I know you know
I'm out here so we gonna talk like
grown-ups is that what we are
[Music]
it's good to see - says what brings you
home
we have unfinished business
we have to go back to where it all
started
lucky us
one thing's for sure gonna be a hell of
a reunion
[Music]
I'm still family back together again you
got fat
[Music]
what's up everybody it's Warren and
phase four of the MCU has officially
begun as we have just got the teaser
trailer for Black Widow now it came out
six hours earlier than it was set to
come out but none of us are complaining
there is a lot to break down the footage
was absolutely incredible and what's
very interesting is that I did a video
maybe a week ago talking about a leaked
description of the trailer it was pretty
much 100% accurate but there is a lot to
talk about with this teaser trailer it
didn't really seem like a teaser trailer
it was over 2 minutes long just barely
but it felt like a real trailer it
introduced us to a lot of characters it
told us a little bit about the plot but
most importantly it showed us some
really awesome action scenes but we're
just going to go through the trailer and
break it all down I'm still doing an
Xbox one and ps4 giveaway all you have
to do to enter that is subscribe but
with the notifications turned on like
the video and leave a comment down below
so the trailer actually starts off with
Budapest it's a place of major
importance to Black Widow we've been
hearing about it since the very first
Avengers film it also has a lot of
relevance to Hawkeye who just may appear
in this movie but I'll talk a little bit
about that later so it opens up on
Budapest and then we go to her dialogue
from Avengers in game where she says I
used to have nothing and as she's saying
this we see flashbacks to her in the Red
Room training to become Black Widow
these are the same shots that we saw
from Avengers age of Ultron but then she
says and then I got this job and then it
flashes to scenes from the very first
Avengers film when she's on the carrier
and then she continues on to say this
family as in now we have this family and
it goes to scenes from the first
Avengers again with her and Hawkeye and
then her and Nick Fury now of course we
know that Hawkeye was actually sent to
kill her Hawkeye was sent on a mission
to take out Black Widow but instead he
made a different call and he actually
brought her in to make her work for
shield so that's why they're showing
Hawkeye and of course Nick Fury because
those are the two people that brought
her in and what's really cool is that an
Avengers end game when she says I used
to have nothing but now I have this
family she's talking about the Avengers
but in this trailer it's actually a
reference to her new family it's a
reference to red Guardian it's a
reference to the new Black Widow you
learn a Bulova and of course Hawkeye as
well but she finishes the dialogue off
with but nothing lasts forever and this
is sort of a call to Avengers in game
and the fact that she's dead right now
but then we reel
dive into the trailer and we start to
get into the new footage it shows the
Marvel Studios logo which turns into the
Black Widow logo in a way as well which
is really really cool so then we cut to
some new footage of Black Widow getting
off a train in a train station and then
we hear the voice of what is presumed to
be at Thunderbolt Ross and he says I
heard you had to leave in a hurry now
remember that this movie is going to
take place between the events of Civil
War and the events of Avengers endgame
so when we hear him say I heard you had
to leave in a hurry he's referring to
the fact that she's wanted now in civil
war at first she was with Tony Stark she
was with the sokovia courts but then she
turned at the very end she helped
Captain America and she helped the
Winter Soldier get away and therefore
she is a criminal now and she's a wanted
fugitive so when he says you had to
leave in a hurry she had to leave
because she's wanted and when she says
it's never easy these days that's what
she's referring to making the right
decisions and then we see here a bunch
of vehicles and convoys and we see
Thunderbolt Ross in a really weird Dee
aged way now Marvel is known to do this
they did this with Captain Marvel for
Nick Fury making him look younger and
they did this with ant-man and the wasp
as well but this is more of like the
ant-man in the wasp version now when we
saw Thunderbolt Ross and Captain America
Civil War and Avengers endgame he was
not this young they weren't making him
look this young so that means of course
that this is in the past because not
only are we going to explore what
happened with Black Widow between the
events of Civil War and infinity war but
we're going to go to her past as well
and clearly Thunderbolt Ross had some
hand in that so then we hear his voice
again and it says so what are you going
to do Black Widow says I've lived a lot
of lives and we see her go through just
a ton of different fake IDs of course
she's a spy that's what they do but she
says I'm done running from my past so
she's referring to the Red Room here and
then it goes to a scene where she enters
a house and we hear the voice of Yelena
Bulova who of course is a different
version of Black Widow but a version of
Black Widow nonetheless so in this scene
it's really cool because you essentially
have two black widows two women who were
trained to be master assassins fight
each other
Natasha enters the room with her gun in
her hand ready to fight and we hear
Ilona Bulova say I know you're out there
it's funny because she actually kind of
sounds like The Scarlet Witch in this
but of course it's Jelena Bulova and she
says I know you're out there of course
because she's been trained as a Master
Assassin
and due to that fact Natasha says I know
you know I'm out here
they were trained in the same way they
were trained to be able to pick up on
everything be aware of everything
so then Natasha says so are we going to
talk like grown-ups and they both turn a
corner and both point the guns right out
each other and we see you'll in a Bulova
Black Widow for the first time in this
trailer Yelena says is that what we are
and then the two of them go at it and
the fight scene is really really good
it's pretty much what we expected to see
it from this movie a lot of hand-to-hand
combat and judging by this trailer it's
all going to be just absolutely awesome
but then eventually the two of them stop
fighting and Natasha says it's good to
see you - assists the two of them are
now friendly they're about to eat some
food together and yelena says what
brings you home now she refers to her as
sister but they're not actually sisters
they're just referring to each other as
that because of the Black Widow program
they were sisters in the Black Widow
program now she asks what brings you
home and the two of them take off on a
motorcycle in true black widow fashion
but then Natasha says we have unfinished
business now what she was referring to
is the Red Room she wants to take down
the Red Room so no more little girls
have to be pulled into this program so
no more little girls have to go through
what she went through and what Yelena
Bolivia went through as well in her
Black Widow training and we hear her
confirm that because she says we have to
go back to where it all started and then
we see an awesome action scene which
actually has three black widows in one
scene we have Natasha Romanoff Black
Widow we have Jelena Bulova Black Widow
and it looks like we have Melina Vostok
off Black Widow as well and what's
really interesting about this next scene
is that we can see two people standing
in basically a blacked-out room staring
at a bunch of computer monitors with a
bunch of red dots on them this is most
likely people in charge of the Red Room
and the dots on the computer screens are
most likely the black widows that they
have but what's really interesting about
this scene is that you can see a woman
on the Left clearly dressed up as a
Black Widow but it is not Natasha
Romanoff and it's not Jelena Bulova it
does look like milena now there has been
some rumors going around that milena
could actually be the villain but
judging by this teaser trailer that does
not appear to be the case it appears
that her and Natasha and red Guardian
and Yelena are very close together we
have this awesome shot of Black Widow in
her new white suit we've seen pictures
of before but this is the first time
that we're seeing the actual white suit
in the trailer she jumps on some type of
rig to take out a bunch of guards they
look like they belong to task
they're wearing sort of similar suits to
him and then we actually see the Red
Room we see a bunch of young black
widows training so this movie really is
going to give us a lot of information
and background on what Natasha Romanoff
went through to become Black Widow and
of course what it took to get out and
then we finally see taskmaster for the
very first time he's riding in his tank
like we saw from the leaked photos but
what's really interesting here is that
he has a bow now it's very interesting
that we don't know who is playing
taskmaster and it has been rumored that
taskmaster isn't actually the villain of
the movie now I'm sure people's first
reactions would be Wow maybe this is
Hawkeye perhaps taskmaster is Hawkeye
now if taskmaster exists in the time
period between Civil War and infinity
war it's definitely not hot guy and it
definitely seems like that is the case
but if Marvel is tricking us and these
scenes are actually in the past which I
don't believe but if they are this could
be Hawkeye but that's just speculation
and probably not true taskmaster
definitely is going to be in the current
time period that the movie takes place
in so Natasha says we're going back
Jelena Bulova says lucky us
then Natasha says one thing's for sure
it's going to be a hell of a reunion and
then we are introduced to red Guardian
now for those of you who are thinking
wow this guy looks a lot like a Russian
version of Captain America that is
exactly what he is during the Cold War
the Russians tried to steal a Super
Soldier Serum they got their hands on
something similar and tried to adapt it
in their own way and this was the
product red Guardian so he's literally
the Russian version of Captain America
but the Super Soldier Serum isn't the
same which is kind of why we see him out
of shape in this teaser trailer and they
even make a joke about it in the trailer
he says family back together and Melina
says you got fat but this is the family
that Black Widow is referring to in the
opening dialogue for this trailer yes it
comes from Avengers in game but now it's
implied that it is about this family and
then the rest of the trailer is just
amazing action we see Red Guardian go up
against taskmaster looks awesome we see
alehna Bulova shooting a rocket launcher
and then we have this final last scene
that is just completely awesome natasha
romanoff a black widow looks to be
jumping off an exploded ship just
soaring through the air while
taskmasters villains chaser shooting her
in
the air and she's just falling through
the sky almost not even faced by it and
then we cut to the new black widow logo
so that was the very first trailer for
Black Widow what did you all think about
this I thought it was absolutely awesome
a great way to kick off phase four of
the MCU it has officially begun we have
a lot more Marvel news coming up this
weekend so be sure to subscribe and turn
on notifications so you don't miss out
on anything also don't forget to like
the video and leave a comment below so
you can enter my giveaway for a chance
to win an Xbox one or a ps4 as always
thank you all so much for watching
woof woof